all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 95 and
it is another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got the latest Star Wars game
cancellation Mortal Kombat 11 reveal of
it anthem in Division 2 and Activision
CFO to discuss so we gonna get right
into it so let's introduce the Four
Horsemen of gaming those original Lords
of the realm here at the roundtable my
co-hosts with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the howl of the young wolf
mommy doing pretty good just you know a
little warning I'll probably be taking
off here in about 15 minutes
oh man I can't help that you know I
decided a snow and I guess like you guys
are supposed to get the snow you guys
are better prepared for this snow okay
yes I'll weathermen a fraud now here we
they said it was what's funny is like
last year we get people acted like we
was gonna get like a foot of snow here
in an ever so mm-hmm
trust me I know the feeling but you were
playing man the only thing I've really
been playing is a game on the switch and
I've been over 100 god I do my soldier
boy joy oh so you you're selling PS
Vita's not gonna hustle me out here jump
and play know it's like Lagrange
Legacy's what it's called it's a really
good game definitely I think it comes up
to 2400 India from another indie it's
it's definitely a good game it's like an
older Final Fantasy feeling yeah when a
lot of overwatch on top of that I've
been playing way too much overwatch it's
a new content no I just really like I
started learning actually how to use
people on the ground just like cuz John
because I used to just like you know
play a couple games quit but John showed
me how to play people and so now like
it's actually because now since I
actually know what I'm doing it's funner
more funner and of course we have both
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also the sastra Davis mr.
Othman profile Illuminati and Lord
patreon of the iron bank mommy Lord
sovereign are you doing sir good man
chillin yeah I'm glad we didn't get that
snowman I was prepping I was ready I was
like why be and I was just like hobbled
into a corner where like we're gonna
watch boxing with and watch movies and
they're not look out the window and it's
raining am i serious no none today
Froy yeah what you can not much of
anything this week I think I clocked
like 75 hours of work this week so very
very little gaming but I did pick up all
the Switch exclusive traffic strikes
back no more arrow I picked that up is
actually what I played of it I have to
say I have to always preamble what I say
with exclusive so the King doesn't jump
down my throat about because I
personally if you don't pick it up King
I think you fraud but
where'd you get that Kevin get a red
switch nah since I can pump that off I
would turn my camera so besides that on
back to the Friday evening I took a
little time off I want to see glass oh
my god yeah man like Solomon betrayed
like honestly if any any fans of
unbreakable and a split you know he sort
of betrayed everyone who loved those two
movies because it's just like he trying
to make a movie for everybody so in
doing that what he did was he gave a lot
of verbal exposition for things you
didn't need to really explain like the
characters actually explained what was
sort of going on and sort of describing
like comic book tropes that you know if
you've seen the movies before you knew
you know that you knew what that stuff
was so it just felt it just felt like it
was sort of a betrayal of everybody who
loved these characters in the previous
two movies it was yeah not great not
great the movies in a little bit yeah
that's that yeah so after intros we'll
come back we'll do uh yeah we do our
gleam runner and also we have a reroll
from last week so I'll do that do I put
a pole no doubt yeah and of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka
the XS Gaber ooh the lord of combat
sports was a man of his convictions
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is the leader of the
fraud alert movement Oh beloved King now
you do exist first of all let me tell
you something um right now I'm calling
fraud on this situation because I'm
under the rules or whatever but you know
I'm under the ropes second of all I
don't know what's going I guess it's
stolen my hair's crazy my Wi-Fi acting
up a little
gay gay so on and I'm like y'all drop
there now that was having issues earlier
but um I didn't get a chance to get up
and do the results show of our Manny
Pacquiao vs. Adrien Broner let me tell
you something last night close you are a
wonderful person
yeah put together stuff you have
teaching these new promoters and these
all promoters exactly how to promote
fights and how to put on for fault that
certain people you can't really put on
you understand um Manny Pacquiao when I
out there and everybody's gonna keep on
yelling out the 40 is 40 old man will
come out at some point in time Adrian
yeah listen man yeah think it's cutting
in and out ring you crazy
alright you can train somebody right now
right yeah yeah you in a now crazy you
might want to drop come back in but I
won't mess up a storm Eddie he's having
slow over the issues boy this is now
keep it going crazy bro afraid you can
turn a person you can tell somebody to
do something but when those knees get to
knock him and I don't mean into beaten
and she's got a little dog eating and I
don't want to use the word you know that
we say in a boxing gym for the person
that who has that in them um you know
you such such made you understand
you know what it is king I just got just
a second everyone it is for all the
joint he be talking and like you I can't
watch another finalist do not and like
he's not even a good villain he's so
he's so trashed that he's not even a
good villain like all you want to see is
him under the rope every time yeah nice
defensive away and he doesn't deserve to
be in any of those fights ever again he
just doesn't say this right the reason
why agent brought oh please I'll God
that you watching this I hope God you
watching this I hope somebody links you
to this and I hope on God you hear this
anytime that you're supposed to get a
fight from now one should be want to
take off brother back did not take a
dollar home because anybody that seen by
two jacks with his head split open like
he got hit with a hatchet in his head
that's crazy
seriously that was insane it looks
literally like somebody took an axe to
his head was too far behind he was not
gonna win but his fighters Hart had him
push the whole card head see they
probably would have like I'm looking
like I remember that Matt Mitrione fight
they called it and like he didn't even
want to because it says Edwin stop
bleeding and it profusely bled but to
speak of somebody else that was bleeding
and from a different orifice glasses a
whole I'm telling you man on everything
man no sir
don't ever put your name in me with his
name of your mouth bruh like you are
nowhere in shape or form
in this guy's circumference and it
in his stratosphere for you to even
think that you can compare to yourself
as this man who built up his legacy who
fought bare knuckles Pretty Boy Floyd or
washed your behind
talking about it like I get so irritated
for trying to make the fight piss me off
Sava King is like the interview do go
get I'll beat that boy I'm like this is
the thing this is what makes him not
even a good villain because it's like
dude
the man has a issues you know it was a
king in his own game he's fighting again
his game in victory for him is surviving
round do you see every round pieces
chest he they're polished it real hot
how do you average eight punches around
[Music]
he's not even worthy
I feel bad but I'll be I felt the fight
I like I self feel your pain cuz it's
like I suck at myself and I said to
myself I'm never gonna watch his face
again
but because it was Pacquiao I was like
maybe Pacquiao get him it could be a
little more excited you guys know damn
well something if he's fighting someone
leg you gotta go watch that fighter yeah
never get my beautiful again yeah no
doubt
Oh your skis the straight-up worse the
word you been playing good oh okay
I was I was lowkey boycotting the game
no but then I brought myself around to
it and I'm strangely getting shout-out
to Chris oh that's what's up I
interviewed those devs and all was a
rebellion they really cool critical guys
one of the greatest games that's on game
path right now but Assassin's Creed
Odyssey is the natural progression in
Assassin's Creed lineage and it turns it
into a semi RPG type of game where
they're trying I know the next
Assassin's Creed has to be a full-blown
RPG because they're blending the the and
blurring the lines between action and
RPG to the point that soon is gonna be
stat rolls on the weapons and maybe the
weapons break why you fighting with them
or you can level up the weapons but they
they took it to a natural progression
man I love the way it's going the
graphics is outstanding shout-out to mr.
boomstick um and I believe you said hole
was in on it right if I like this is so
much game there you yeah you talk to me
like in the year party or dinner and
then and I was like man I really feel
like this game just never gonna end like
one I got like sixty two hours into it
I'm just like this game's literally
never gonna end
killing them dogs in the back you know
when the snow come they gotta get real
flat forty nights it's my roommates
daughters well yeah like I'm so
disappointed well as if I just shout out
this rock to go and celebrate with Manny
Pacquiao
so all this rock man I mean I'm in
disbelief people hitting me up yo King
should I order to fight you'll do not
call me ask for your money I'm not like
Vicki I wouldn't I wouldn't be gonna
work if I was doing sushi stuff like
Michael Vick was doing he make me too
much money the lord of the cooperative
experience and the gaming injure himself
the shinobi lord Cognito spread never
illness in the room and ILP not telling
you what you want to hear but what you
need to hear
UFC last I saw USC Achilles show the man
everybody was talking about this is dude
he beat one man Cody twice it was like
he's to do yes I know listen man like I
did what I give did I saw is this right
Dylan saw came back he took her he took
a close loss to uh to Dominick Cruz came
back better to himself by that time Cruz
had lost he gotten wiped by gar Brandt
and then gar Bragg our brands a great
fighter in terms of pure skill he
doesn't have the best fight IQ in the
business he's not about making
adjustments mid-fight and demonsaw wiped
him twice there were stars the great
fighter that said he had to go up
against the huto come
down 10 pounds to fight Sahul this is
the dude the Mighty Mouse yeah this is a
kid that he's a little bit wrestler yeah
Olympic wrestler always always improving
since he took that first loss to Mighty
Mouse he took that to heart has come
back powder in every single fight this
kid this is his moment this is his time
I figured he's willing to fight anyway
but I thought it was gonna be wrestling
that was gonna do that was gonna do TJ
in yeah and he came into saying no this
is my weight class I'm gonna prove that
this won't class and Mesa stay I'm going
to wipe the flow with you and you could
tell like it's hard to call me a corny I
was saying like he's biting look like he
doesn't but he doesn't want to let TJ
stand back up yeah and he just he
floored him he just totally wiped the
flow with him and he he he bombarded him
in a way that he TJ just could not get
out of that like you know I have liked
it to go a little bit longer
yeah listen the stoppage I thought I
thought he was still scrambling there
was a moment when you seen it in slow-mo
again well he went me played a fight fan
I know you was screaming yeah could they
give him a second let me jump because I
say about that part did I get me mad and
I feel he was getting blitzed right
there was no he'll be your body you lost
consciousness he was slipping in and out
of consciousness like two times so once
that happened okay you're scrambling at
the end they could have gave you a
couple more seconds but don't try to act
like you was about to do something ill
from you say like cut that out I did the
other thing is like oh man like bro they
think like I can't go know what I'm
talking about
cuz it reminds me of my man Roy and I
never forget when he won the heavyweight
championship remember okay and he came
down and weight immediately to face
taller that was the beginning of the end
because people don't realize when you
drops that much weight the must all that
stuff around the brain
that takes longer to come back so your
chin tends to go a lot of dudes is doing
this dropping real quick and wait they
got a chill so I'm telling you his he he
looks sauce King okay guy he was all
over the place
wow you know watching and I couldn't get
a chance to see and I was let me get it
and watch when I got home and I said I'm
gonna talk to you all if I wanted to do
and I was gonna be a fraud right now boy
right now and pull it up right now and
I'll tell you this if if they do fight
at 135 as the hooter goes up I think I
think he still kind of Dunstable him
because he was walking around when he
isn't is 130 132 so it's not gonna be a
problem
he's like yeah we can run it back yeah
if you like that because even though
he's trying to get paid like right now
they run that back that's gonna be a
killer short did that decotis is gonna
be the same I just you know say and I'm
telling you to get beat the way he got
beat that messes with you mentally you
know everything so we gonna see but over
the next hour Greg Hardy with his
illegal knees cowboy I mean for gaming
for me I'll shout out to I wish I was
doing it all definitely scored a pass
rate for the first time so I was messing
around with that shout the pyro you know
sandy box his game of fort a stone wolf
and the crew is getting it in man it's a
fun way they just out speaking their own
attic I know he stepped out for a bit
but they just need to get some story
exposition with
that they did a good job with last wish
but for whatever reason this one you
just need to know why you doing it cuz
it's like the three sections of the raid
is mad cool it's like you know one part
of it is almost like some Indiana Jones
you could use your own sparrows in the
raid and escape in this evil server the
thing it got its fire you don't say in
the last part it's like you facing this
metal gear take Boston you gotta shoot
these different parts of a titanfall
kind of boss thing so Elliot got back on
the messenger force which still been
doing that have a lot of fun with that
and I've downloaded that uh MK tensile
or a game pass yeah go fast after seeing
you know yeah you get you got the feels
I know I know is that wearable or is it
a Master Chief situation dirty taste
don't you behave no destiny hopefully
but anyways get into that a Kingdom
Hearts situation oh absolutely so uh
last night our gleam giveaway for
Kingdom Hearts 3 came to a conclusion
thank you all of you that are that
supported and got in there and got
entered into that so oh there was a
you'd have to ask now though that but
there was a lot we got a shout out what
our old geez day one more monkey punch
with the $3.00 super chat just thank you
and you don't you know not only is that
love like punch be the first person in
the impact everyone asked my do you want
to come back to the shop for a drink on
me brother we're gonna do it again
but anyway continue rock you for style
bar code number nine in them
so let me see okay so the winner of our
kingdom hearts 3 gleam giveaway is Lord
Alexander Trudeau aka the squall on
Twitter like that name is Guam extract
out congratulations to the strong on
Twitter Lord Alexander Trudeau I will be
getting be hitting you up in the DMS
later today with your code for your game
so that way you're ready to go on the
29th I believe the game launches so you
be all downloaded and ready to go so
congratulations once again and thank you
to everyone who participated in the
giveaway early middle of with tremendous
and we love doing this type of data
community fantastic shoot a shout-out to
the squall PD in a chat oh now though
for administering this whole thing like
now no on it no his ban hamma
is ill yo then which I try to getting
them them are Gleaners be fraudulent so
that's not going stay tuned for the next
stay tuned for the next one yeah
actually we haven't decided what game we
go do it absolutely yeah we have that
reroll from last week Lord cat daddy has
graciously offered to pay forward his
$20 gift card giveaway win from last
week so we're gonna re-roll that right
now alright so let's get that drumroll
the Attic love
the winner of the $20 gift card giveaway
is Lord Slammy Prescott gratulations
Lord Sammy
native out here saying we fraud and we
Regulus good family never won combat
yesterday not one time did I see you pop
your little head out apologies apologies
to last week's winners - I've been a
little this last week was crazy so I
will get all of your codes and stuff to
you during this long weekend morning
moon or lap show no no no so I'll get to
the pole with the announcement of
managing parting ways from Activision
and assuming full publishing rights of
the Destiny franchise what do you think
is the best course of action for Bungie
moving forward the winner at 58% of the
Bungie dating game was the stay single
and multi plant crew coming in at second
at 21% was the hey girl Phil's on 15%
was the sony out here at 91 million live
your best life grooming it at last place
and only 6% was change of heart
we roll in with that epic group so shout
out to all the lords who participated in
last week's poll section what do the
lords think about this I think about
this any time the man
early a solo but I think like I said
like that gives you the opportunity to
do somebody when they feel like it so
yeah is fire tamati the original pub
dream
everybody we know so yeah let's get it
to stop which I'm glad he's gonna join
us in midstream so I'll finish him
returns and you would reveal man let's
break this thing down in three parts man
let's break it down
um shout out to canker me I used to do
it but it's a jazz lit right now
Bordeaux combat reveal you know me so I
wanted to bring it down to epochs let's
talk about one you know what we saw you
know thoughts about the reveal itself
then too I want to talk about that
collector's edition that $300
collector's edition you know I'm saying
and you know last part of it we'll talk
about is the switch version let's get it
up the King first because died of his
approach
I know feel just want to reveal it shout
out to hip-hop gamer so hip-hop Graham
when we live on Instagram and he was
watching the reveal and he is the
greatest if if you
and again have that man reveal your game
son he shouted this game oh my god oh my
god and I was screaming right along with
him like when I saw it I said first of
all when we first sorted the chilla the
CGI a vertical slice or whatever we saw
up dude we thought it was the doubtful
gaze he is not gonna look like that
thank God they listened to me and didn't
use that 21 savage music thank you shout
out to Joe and savage in the bush good
conversation five stuff Thanks
oh we push true question the real
question are we rush it to the next
generation did you see what this game
look like good what you think so I mean
they almost feel like everything's
hitting its stride right almost like
that's what happens man like when you
have a generation that runs long again
like you know before last gen in a race
until five years and you're out next you
know last gen because of you know the
economy and what what have you blasted
nearly anywhere from eight to ten years
people would say so yeah games get more
of an opportunity to people you know get
to know the hardware and and stuff just
starts looking and running better and
they start to maximize what these
machines can do and now you know
everybody's moving on to the next thing
so I mean can it be argued that we're
always trying to move too fast yeah
absolutely but I mean hey whatever comes
down the pipeline like this it's looking
fantastic
cyberpunk last of us all this stuff is
gonna be looking ridiculous and but hey
but it yeah it looks like it does not
belong on this gospel generation jump
into cos like same thing as king when I
first sort of giant like I state when I
saw always a game Awards right we were
like vertical slice you know this cool
look nice you know boy a year share the
21
I agree with you psychic without 21
Savage straight in the bushes I wasn't
there and then don't expect the hip hop
being on edges he wasn't the right
stylistic choice he's just not the
choice so but the joint oh and I'm
seeing it and I'm like man like it's it
looks so crazy
yeah I'm saying is it's more out of
control than ever
and I'm just proud of him like cuz
that's been real like Mortal Kombat had
that stage like maybe before 9:00 right
I mean they were in the bushes like they
were trying to find themselves it is not
too late almost did that soft reboot
with 9:00 and reintroduced it and it
came back with a passion so and what I
like what they doing it did I see the
story will reveal yeah yeah I don't know
man like it's just one thing about them
I respect the story mode is one of the
best story modes I feel in fighting and
the Canadians the best the best from
injustice yes and that story that you're
talking about when they take they can
take evil Superman and they work with it
and they saw how explosive that became
mmm-hmm now just take way to make rate
and evil make make the God that we love
you know some evilness and they use it a
same formula but gravity bro it's crazy
man
so yeah I was definitely impressed with
that I don't know what engine a user
with nether Amazon it's unreal right I
think it is on it you know so that's the
first one definitely one jump in on that
you know I want to get into also unless
King let's finish with the graphic
citizen person okay I want to get into
like that collector's edition so what we
got well we got we got the $300 you know
a game style giant and did they talk
about : to Sub Zero
mask you know said you get the mass now
mind you King we are getting the game
we're getting the game harder yeah in
close
they learn from other dudes dropping
$500 system games with no game inside so
we got that we got the exclusive steel
case at magnet
we got a 1x1 yeah scorpion mask collect
this box you don't say so like is this
is this out of control this is a very
conflicted topical to it I'm seeing
people on both sides of the fence
I'm saying people saying like shot the
Boomer yo that's date one yours and so
oh he showed his receipt he got his
pre-order let me say first of all take
yourself to anybody who wants their crap
don't don't do it go to sideshow if
you're Mortal Kombat fangota sideshow
calm Sideshow Collectibles calm going
there put a Mortal Kombat and actually
go pick up statues and stuff like that
you can get a full-size bus for that
price oh and you your characters face
and all that and you can put it to the
side and it looks beautiful for that you
go buy the game for $35 digital whatever
do whatever you gonna do but do not buy
that mask you guys they got that velvet
bag from the plastic so don't do it you
remember I said okay Jane I might look
good in my mama office fair mannequin
head
and I'm gonna laugh because if you need
i say get the game up front and by the
end of the year that thing's gonna be
$50 you know Mortal Kombat phase
yeah that's fan base is so rabid if I
don't chop what is honest you spend $300
on a steep dough man like job like like
you see 150 maybe - they just don't
trade - three
there was no upward trend - this is 300
is that way your last console was - he
needs a companion for his master chief
harder exactly okay without
okay we just we just fell off with this
debacle
close to release so we got there now
let's get to what we're here for so it
looks like this is a confirmed game had
a mortal kombat yes actually and I
remember PSVita had one you know it was
pretty solid but I was salad oh stop
stop stop
I said Game Gear mm-hmm remember when
Super Nintendo and your mortal combat
with the Sweat right
and then you had Genesis mm-hmm the
Mortal Kombat then you had game gear and
get with the switch okay yeah while
fighting
so here's the thing like we got we heard
obviously the exists
the reveal happened there was no footage
of this thing to be found so a wonderful
start of a solve so how are they going
to do this off like what do you feel
like what what any shot at 60fps I don't
know I don't think so I don't think so
but again who knows man Ali like we've
been saying like you know the switch is
worth it almost going on two and a half
years like they figured out some magic
to do with that stuff obviously it's not
gonna be the premiere version it's gonna
be a sideshow version for me it's gonna
be the version that I practice on while
I'm not home and you know and that's
what it's gonna be the fact that it's
even coming it's cool but yeah I know I
know King doesn't agree with this but
listen all of the effort has been put
like it say what Wolfenstein doom those
games aren't supposed to be on switch
and they run like if you play those
games on the switch obviously they are
the worst versions of those games but
they don't feel like they really don't
feel like they're their detracting from
the game like if you play that version
you you get a sense of what the game is
it's not like you're playing a totally
broken destroyed version of that kick
you're gonna shadow a bit is okay versus
switch burns gonna have that green is
sweat blood they're gonna have the SNES
blood to follow like were they wrong to
not show this which virgin did they say
day and date did they say day and date
or is it more along they haven't even
released that spec as to win if it
releases the indie that may not even be
there new to be honest I will see
because because Mortal Kombat is what
April
there's no way then no mega chest as
much will be two years it'll be interest
because it's like do day in day so you
thinking that is no way if they didn't
mention it they you're right they didn't
mention it they did a it was just kind
of alluded to that they didn't show
anything of it I doubt very much is
ready to go by that date but King
argument could be made for the switch
fanbase which is very huge to say yo
that's for sabit on that yeah I'm not
showing a version I give us no
information on let's let the real stuff
fall out first big switch fan base that
needs to know about this everybody
release database is used to waiting so
you have no sympathy for the food which
made me like they have okay there's no
green shots there's no [ __ ] they just
they did I just got a hole that they
can't have made up there have no certain
things aren't made for everyone like
some people should not wear skinny jeans
you understand like you know that dude
that's walking down the street that
should not be where he's trying and they
make it in his size
Nintendo switches skinny jeans of our
industry bro no oh I don't know I think
I think I think they do need to get some
information out yeah mention it that
means this is probably not day in there
for long night is gonna pop up inside
the store and yogur had to buy it
without previewing it or anything right
and yes mom
boy is it that like false advertising
they have nothing to go by except the
Xbox one X in the PlayStation 4 didn't
they didn't they do that didn't the 2k
do that with them with the wrestling
game that people like you didn't really
get your hands on it until it was
horrible it was a disaster and that's
all I'm saying like from at some point
even if you don't want to show it at
that event I get that you like you know
what we got this X 1x goodness PC
PlayStation 4 Pro we're not trying to
embarrass and put you know some Vaseline
graphics or no 485 I get that but at
least have the sideshow of him you don't
say or like I'll be after event when you
black okay you could sit down with it
and then we can give you the closed-door
footage so people could say yo I played
it but man have any yeah I'm telling you
and the way you move that version of the
game right cuz there are gonna be people
who just don't get the switch version
you know for debris that's the one they
want but um the West for me the way you
move that version of the game is that
you save just for the record King says
the switch has no user base
right now he kills us over here for
bring that bad boy over the previous
experience you don't know what the
resolutions gonna be where there's so
point
realtor what do you what do you think is
the technical framework like do you
think is any chance at hell they'll do
60 frames or they gotta do
notoriously busy like realtalk like the
the PS Vita joint they had was the MK 9
it was 60 frames it was probably like 40
peor whatever was but they they took all
affects our entire lives and all I dream
all that craziness it was 60 days
they've had a history of doing good
ports the question is because how insane
you know sacrifices I mean the games you
know so that's a you know I mean almost
better but anyway but real talk more
calm everything looks fantastic man
series continues to blow us away they
own an injustice wave I mean I'm just
proud of MORTAL KOMBAT as a franchise
that they continue to thrive they keep
getting better and this thing looks
amazing I cannot wait we got your
obviously you know they go do the DLC
characters and what if they do the the
movie tie-ins and all that
stuff well yeah I'm height man I'm high
definitely there's definitely awesome
day one for a fat everybody would this
be phrase they got a chill and that's
all I got
Lord Soph what is going on with Star
Wars what is going on with Stowers that
is the question so uh last week Jason
Shire broke the story that the open
world Star Wars game that was being
developed at EA Vancouver was canceled
so just a little history on this the
open-world game at EA Vancouver was
originally the game that Amy Hennig was
working on um over with visceral which
is kind of like the single-player
Uncharted esque I guess the code name
was rag tag for that game uncharted ask
a single player action adventure game
that was cancelled by EA Amy Hennig uh
afterwards left EA and then visceral was
shut down and the a lot of the assets
from that game were moved over to actual
actually to motive Jade Raymond's studio
at the time and motive kind of merged
with Vancouver and it became one entity
and continued to work on this game now
gonna be an open-world game in the Star
Wars universe so word from Jason
Schreyer is that this game was cancelled
because not because there was anything
wrong with it not because it was not
coming together the game was cancelled
because it was not gonna be ready in the
timeframe that EA wanted it to be with
AI 2020 this is a game that was gonna
take them to at least 2021 2022 to be
ready and that is not they wanted to
release another game in in an earlier
time frame so what they cancelled this
game to make a smaller more focused game
ie probably what Amy Hennig game was
going to be
and they're gonna rush this game out now
to be ready by 2020 um this is honestly
like this is the biggest bungling of the
Star Wars franchise I've seen since the
prequels and in the movie verse um
this is I don't quite understand why I
can so I can sort of understand where
this is coming from I think if you look
at EA now EA is if you look at uh what
is the name of know they see the
Alexander um oh yeah yeah look at Andrew
Wilson I think he is not happy with that
10-year deal they made that ten-year
deal went into effect actually before
his tenure so and I think if you look at
what EA is looking to do now they're
looking to focus more on their own IP
and I think Star Wars and and that
relationship with Disney where Disney is
is sort of this overseer and they've
sort of proven to be notorious to work
with it has made it difficult for them
to it's just something then they're not
they don't really want to do right now
and right it just feels like unless it's
something that's gonna make them uh a
buttload of money over and over again
like a battlefront which with the
intention of battlefront um so do you
think it's a question of do you think
Disney is having second thoughts of
actually being in bed with EA especially
after the Battlefront
I don't absolutely again I don't know I
don't know what their involvement is to
the point of you know of a game being
canceled I don't know how that works how
much how much control they have in that
respect but if you look at what they've
done with with the Marvel licenses and
they've spread that out you know they
gave spider-man 2 at insomniac and Sony
the the Avengers game is gonna be
multiplied by all accounts everything
else coming they're sort of spreading
the wealth out a need to ensure that
something does come out right and they
can you know that we use where they can
have multiple Marvel uh franchises
coming out and be you don't put all your
eggs in one basket with one developer
arm that again has to constantly produce
so I to me
if they had it all to do over again I
would say yeah they would take the same
approach that they're taking with the
Marvel licenses if you look at like even
when you look at you know Marvel
Ultimate Alliance 3 with the switch
right that game even if that game is
trashed
it's gonna sell gangbusters because it's
only on the switch obviously the
internet had a load of opinions on this
um and I want you guys think us to me it
to me it's pretty disgusting to be
honest cuz you bothered me about this is
that you can be sure that that unless
you know Disney pulls out of this deal
some way shape or form and I would love
to have Lord Hogan here to see you know
this kind of his opinion on that sort of
stuff but unless they pull out of this
deal you can be sure as hell that battle
for 3 is coming out Yankee games coming
out I mean I'm not a Star Wars fan like
Jess I'm not even gonna fright but at
the end of the day I just feel bad for
me no it's like like was it the project
Orca Star Wars we're supposed to be cool
just like what every project she's
associated with is always some creative
control scandal and get canceled I'm not
saying she's the problem I'm just saying
I just feel bad for there's like you
know she's apparently obviously this
really good person as far as making a
great story or you know contributing to
these great story driven games so it's
like to see another project of hers now
not come out you know it's concerning
and then obviously we got to see there
now redirecting it to this other media
project that's gonna come out around
anaconda in the new PS 5 or whatever
that's where a smaller scale now
open-world whatever but that starting
from scratch right now basically I know
and then you know we got the only thing
I got a little hope on is the respawn
one doesn't respawn has a Star Wars
income and that's the thing though
there's no there was no indication to
that game as a single-player game me hmm
there is blue indicates people are
assuming that and and I hope so I hope
so you based on the titanfall 2 uh
a campaign I would love it to be yeah
and that could be the case right maybe
this game got canceled because they said
okay we already have this a game of this
ilk in the pipeline we don't need
another one of these right like it seems
like I don't want to say is the death
distinct I see what you're gonna solve
the death of single play but it's like
she's associated with those strong
single-player style narrative yeah it's
I think it's may thing they just they
don't want to make those type of turning
into a continued revenue stream type
game serving people right so in going
into that focus those single story
drivel driven games
our main focus that's not that bread and
butter they they want to do and also
look at it this way they can't put loot
crate's I'm sorry
so to get the revenue from the Luke
Ray's that's how they would have offset
it you know in the past they would all
set in that fashion did but these dudes
is making such a outrage about Lu crazy
like you'll just pull the game see what
happens when y'all out here trying to
push your story a little narrative
around the game cancelled because it
could have still put this game out loot
crate's involved and then make up the
rest of the bread that way but now
you're gonna get a game probably um you
said i don't believe i believe that next
game i'm probably gonna do multiplayer
something am i right don't you feel a be
definitely yeah yeah i just you know say
like I said it's just frustrating to me
to see like oh again you know I'm saying
here we go again which Star Wars you
know in three days just like you can't
tell me that Disney is not sitting there
reconsidering why did we you know go to
bed where the heat would be a because I
mean okay what you do what you doing
what you do
III don't think Disney is questioning
that whole thing because Disney has
enough capital to absorb them the loss
if they actually take the dissolved
contract with them so I believe they
have enough capital to you know just you
know absorb it with no problem but I
believe that the games that do come out
from be a are of a higher quality
you know the battlefront games and those
games do do well they do sell well in
light of other games of that ilk
they are not in the top tier as
performance wise but they're in the
middle ground and they make a good money
and they usually come out when the
smooth Star Wars movie is coming out
maybe is not a new Star Wars movie
coming out at that period of time and it
doesn't fall in line with how they want
it to come out so I just believe it is
like a timing issue and and the loot
crate thing I honestly believe so cuz
you can't my guys off yeah what bothers
me is that if you're I could for me as
the stars man I'm just speaking
personally as a Star Wars fan
what I love most about that universe is
just that the universe and the smaller
stories you can tell within that
universe
I've already seen how off the million
times I've already seen you know the
Battle of Endor a million times I don't
need to see that again just prettier I
want to I want a smaller story that
shows like the the underlying stuff that
goes on in that universe right and I
think Star Wars hardcore Star Wars fans
want that sort of stuff they want
something like a coat or that yet that
dives deep into lower right you know and
they just did they don't want to give us
the whatever reason they're like you
know we're not giving you that I want to
go back to with the chest shot the own
punch is that it's like somebody's gotta
utilize her talent like that's that's my
thing like Microsoft can make the core
game press come on over here because it
seems like wherever you're going whoever
you're aligning yourself with whether it
be EA or the nori dog situation they're
not valuing what you do so come on
please wait your value because clearly
it's not it over there and yeah it's sad
to see it all I would say is I hope she
is involved on some level or the new
project took own thing I don't so when
she left EA she was like yeah I'm doing
my own thing um I don't know if she
mentioned if some opportunity arose that
she'd be interested in doing something
but
Bilby homeless man let's go baby what's
up yeah yeah I can hear me yeah thank
you for coming through brother
appreciate it man what do you think
about all this Star Wars stuff man
what's going on I mean just see you guys
a heads up I know everybody had like
mixed feelings but I was actually a big
fan of the battlefront that they came
out with not the second one even though
I appreciate the campaign but the first
one like I spent like between Xbox and
Playstation I spent hours like Christmas
vacation on that thing um but as far as
like the games in cancer it is it's
troublesome because every time anything
that has to do that's like Amy Amy her
name is or something like that I feel
like is either the verge of shutting
down can't so I feel like she's not
getting her doing she's like some highly
praised what writer for games you know I
mean so I feel like yeah I'd really
don't understand like what their chances
of what they're trying to do when they
took their the Star Wars deal or just
deal with Disney they have what they had
the battlefront you had respawn and they
had what visceral doing a game rate so
the m3 Studios there was dedicated to
this and all they came out with his
battlefront pretty much yeah that's it
yeah I don't know it was a game a kids
because I could have sworn this right
this multiplayer game did they just
cancelled was you were using assets from
Amy Amy hanoks game right so basically
that game was gonna be more like a
single-player you know sort of like
Uncharted type experience very focused
very linear and but it was gonna be a
story in the store right that we know
but the thing is Nick cancelled this one
now that was supposed to be an
open-world game in the Star Wars
universe they cancelled it simply
because it was gonna be ready in the
time for him that they wanted
to be ready not because there's anything
wrong with the game yeah so they
canceled this one in order to rush out
another one to have it ready by 2020
instead of 20 21 22 where the other one
was gonna be ready that's that's and the
thing is in that timeframe what kind of
game can you make in that timeframe
right smaller more focused game kind of
like what Amy Hennig was doing because
it could be I'm not saying those games
are small like Uncharted takes forever
to make yeah they said we were working
now on a smaller game that'll be ready
by 2020 it could be just a multiplayer
only smaller game yeah there's no
indication what type of game that is so
I really believe it has to be a
regeneration of revenue it has to be one
of those games where engagement becomes
key so they can buy like t-shirts and
stuff like that or they can buy blasters
or you know you can get older one can
know we about purchasing her you know it
has to be a way for them to get
continuous cash and I know EA is on that
wave she needs to go to Sony Sony is the
king she was there we had Naughty Dog go
back by because maybe they lured her
over there you can make these games that
you like to make and then the the
hierarchy changed and she's no longer
viable when they go in a different
direction now for know I get y'all
definitely hate I don't think it's her
fault I don't feel that she has specific
skill set it just seems that with these
big you know publishers that for
whatever it just doesn't fall in line
with what they're trying to do either
from a monetization standpoint on what
have you so it generated or her games
seem to fall the wayside my thing is if
she didn't read what somebody's gonna it
has to be with somebody that's willing
to let her do her thing and rap-metal
factly that's all I'm seeing like
jihadist lis belongs to Sony
but it didn't the whole thing start with
the whole Noah dog and in the Uncharted
and they wanted to go the direction in
you know I don't want to get into
conjecture but like either they kicked
her off the project I didn't feel the
direction whatever they went something
somewhere other direction and then all
of a sudden she's you know she's out so
in you know it's tough it's tough
because you would think Sony is the
place but I don't know man and then
again I could be you know championing
the pompon and outta me it's a real
issue with the way she does things I
don't want to be you know when there's
always an issue
and then the common denominator is one
fine then you're gonna have to start
looking at the fact that yes and I know
nobody here wants to put that form of
indictment on an individual at all
without knowing anything at all and I
don't know a damn thing
mm-hmm but I do say this if it walks
like a duck is a duck I also want to say
mm-hmm give one shot and let her get a
damn game out that's what I'm seeing so
we can see if it is her exactly that's
what I'm saying just let her finish for
my in terms of the work I mean no it's
not her like she's she's able to put out
a great story in a game like she says
she's done this she's proven that it's
just a bite for me like I don't who
knows how she knew maybe she's a diva or
whatever the case may be like who knows
that you know but I think I think EA was
just the absolute it was either EA or
Activision would have been like the
worst places for her to go just because
just because of you know their their
culture is changing to be like you said
they need to monetize every little last
thing that's what they want this is what
this is where they going and that's just
not the place for her you know it seemed
Jade Raymond left
datagram left the same thing they took
that they took motive kind of out from
under her it took the Star Wars game out
from under her daydream about she's like
I'm out I mean obviously I you know
where I would prefer her in my unbiased
a pain I think Ubisoft would be a nice
spot because there's
versity of games in content that they
put out they have a good balance between
monetization single player experiences
or in this part this part don't need no
extra so I got a because Ubisoft
have been the ones that been able to
throw monetization in their games in a
way that's unobtrusive like it's not you
can you can engage with it or you can
not an experience doesn't change like
they're there the dues is like yo you
want to skip this role part right here I
got out of C for free right shout out to
Microsoft foreshadow to Discover Card I
told you how to do the Hustle I got it
for free so I'm talking to Kris while we
playing the game
yeah I said yo I got this for free so I
got a free $50 yeah and he looks like
what I see yeah I'm still going right
now and I bought the biggest package
they had inside
so he don't like what I do cuz he found
this stuff in the game Jonathan B so you
got Amy hiding in one of them boxes
behind you I'm with kid though pick up
the phone get in game pads getting one
of them studios out there the last thing
I want to say about this is that another
thing that sort of dis cancellation sort
of indirectly affects is the weight on
anthems shoulders the weight on napkins
shoulders is already big right perfect
transition this yeah this kind of
amplifies that even more because it
shouldn't but it does
because you know for many people this is
Bioware is like this is their last
chance
Bioware this game has to hit and with
the knowledge that you're probably not
getting any more of this the
single-player type stuff at all from EA
and some perform they gonna try to get
around making this type of game yeah I
just think it just it just puts a lot of
undue pressure on anthem like major
triple-a that like come on like you see
what happened with a battlefield like
that how that blew up in a face anthem
is really kind of like they have to be
the saving grace what's tricky right now
the kids move alright so obviously we
got a lot of news recently dropping this
week obviously we have anthem we know
that closed VIP demo is coming you don't
know saying so we got that coming up
next week and you can invite your three
friends the vision dropped some crazy
news and a lot of stuff on PvP dark zone
and that stuff so as we getting close to
the release of both of these major
franchises that's gonna try to compete
in lieu the shooter space with destiny
it's gonna bring this to the Lord just
as King's topic I'll let him set it off
you know based on the news that we've
heard on both anthem and division or
what's your feeling like what got you
excited what's going on alright so
normally I'm gonna purchase and I played
uh the Division two
when I was at our fan fest and I got a
chance to sit back and also watch the
game being played graphically when I
first displayed the game I was blown
away like everybody else and I thought
the game wasn't gonna be whatever it was
I've been wrong numerous occasions
graphically going into these games and
they are actually what they turned out
to be but the biggest problem with the
division was never the graphics the
biggest problem with the division was
the story the dog's own implication and
how to do PvP versus PvE and then merged
the words the worlds together
thanks alright so you never had the
problem linking up with your friends he
was always able to link up with friends
mm-hmm
but when you went to the dark zone he
was terrified of these grinders like we
were going in a certain time in a shout
out to hot monkey love we will go into
the dogs home at a certain time when
these kids was in school so we can
actually have fun or come three o'clock
when these dudes come home because they
were rolling around going rogue and
everything now the setup system that
they have with three different dark
zones they have our 40 hours of story
that's all that leads to and I'm gonna
get to that in a second and then they
have other meat and potatoes that they
were working around with the game
I think is what should think did they
show enough to turn the crowd that
either gave them that back because
destiny had a moment with you okay my
back but they're back to get back to
destiny destiny has got to a good place
mmm is this that good place for division
with what you've seen mmm I got a lot to
say about the room I want to I want to
bring it back to I wanna bring it back
to you king with anthem cuz you seem to
be not bad and I wanted more
everybody acts is right before anthem
drops right boom for the five hours for
the month this is a hustle skinny jeans
with the skinny oh and now I want you to
go pay to $5 at EA access get anthem
back test drive the car purchase it
right so you see that one there's no
story to it works for you if you want
the Ironman simulator oh my god it's
respect three if linking up with your
friends and everything is easy enough
for you and it could fit because in this
come this crowded world of looter
shooters with destiny that has a fan
base neck Asian and Bungie is separated
so you have hope destiny has hope right
the vision is giving you facts they drop
the effects and it's not dropping any
information nom which on that you're
very coy with a lot of things I will
give you that I'll give it so anytime
somebody keeps you in the dark with
something this crime I I'm telling you
take your hours go get EA access this is
the easiest in the smartest move that
you can make if you lost five dollars
you lost for others you didn't lose $60
game don't like it though right in the
bushes let me
let me get kid on this movie as I'm very
curious you know I know kid you know I'm
not known you're not known to me is like
they're the Luther shooter guy he's it
two big ones coming and I doubt of it -
you know give me your impressions of
division whether you stand what you
heard so far
give me impression someplace oh it's for
me these shooters it's hard to jump on
the bandwagon for me like I try with the
division I had Division one on PC and
Xbox and I just found I was just like uh
I can't get with it you know at me I
need to rely on someone to play that
[ __ ] right
and then the Division two is like
alright I'm interested I mean the only
thing I guess I'm excited about is that
Xbox that's the marketing bill again
that's the only thing but far as like
jumping into it's like you know what hmm
I could care less about the video - but
however for some reason and anthem it's
like can you yeah this is a beer wagon I
could probably jump on if I find
something you know how you guys jumped
on destiny like man it is so now you
were able to create this culture and you
have something to go to them like all
right maybe anthem right could be that
for me maybe not me I see things like
with the extended game play and they had
like these deep dives into the game that
I just got emailed actually a deep dive
coming April the characters the progress
yeah so I'm like okay this is I'm
hurryin bring this beta rating this demo
the only thing that does get get me
about anthem is that the problem is the
one thing about the division that give
respect it's the division I can like
alright the only thing that's really
comparable to destiny is that they're in
the same category right anthem kind of
has those you got that little freakin
robot that sounds like a little Fulton
thing in destiny and it creates like the
same sort of light to me to me it has a
little bit too much similarities to
Destiny's just in the first person and
you're flying you know I mean I prefer
the graphics of anthem I prefer the
javelins and army of ant climb and stuff
like that and I feel like I think the
concept of anthem I prefer more but they
do have a lot
with destiny and personally me I just
thought destiny was a boring experience
I know it is probably just want to get
in the ground floor something that's
about story so great about that so
that's a job is about that good nothing
money because it has nothing else
there's no PvP right right there's no
PvP or lunch oh you you know you can't
do iron banner that's what they don't
have division oh but I'm about to say
something that Kings not going to go for
me I actually pre already asked them
back in November
Microsoft love is all love baby bunny
back to Jake yeah here you go let me let
me get the the Luna shooter champion in
on this asking me about vision to uh my
game share partners getting it so I hang
it but uh I'll say like honestly I
didn't play with it I didn't play a lot
with people I play with King a little
bit the first time through before the
dogs on stuff even came out I played a
little bit and I know I enjoyed the
cover shooting mechanics and stuff like
that what bothered me about division
the first division was that I was
expecting an actual straight-up RPG
New York City that's what I thought it
was gonna be and then when it you know
if more info came out I was like oh no
this is me I mean so again I'm not
excited at all really for for Division
two I'll play it um I'm not particularly
exciting for anthem either but what but
but it is you know I have this thing
with Centurions and Ironman like I like
so it's knew exactly why aware if on
those fronts yeah if it did exactly we
talked about Casey Hudson on this game
like I'm going to give that a chance at
least the story stuck in trees about
grinding response or whatnot I'll play
through the story I'll probably enjoy
that I'm not grinding for weapons I'm
not grinding for armor so I'm sure I'm
sure the story's longer than 10 hours I
can't get past that you know what it is
the conversation might be different if
if people were allowed to talk about it
and what they played so far I could talk
about it now because it's out there
everybody's got the videos I mean listen
yeah no I mean King no I was the biggest
hater of this game preface this point
right just do their job listen a - right
now we go play the game he was under a
nondisclosure agreement right that he
could not disclose what he's touched
when we could talk now
thought let's give now also not for
touching is going to like I said I'm the
biggest haters game yo kid when what
what III they Phil come up with stage'
in the show with anthem lose 20 2017 I
remember it like it was yesterday was in
that crowd I saw that demo and I pulled
the King I had my I have my fraud light
on I said no way is that game moving
like that and that's a vertical slice
I was holding true to that then Digital
froggy somewhat collaborated my story
and they were like yeah you know that it
uh but as you've gotten closer as it's
come out as I got my hands on it I'm
telling ya right now that's it and what
you see that is the game so I'm sitting
there and I'm like oh hey that was first
interview gold how many people said
other games was the game off just a demo
just a beta like I'm not saying it's the
game that it's gonna be the best game
I'm just saying that most games that
graphic or slice and then get the game
and is dumb down I'll give you that I
still got questions on anthem just like
King got all I was like I just feel I
feel like in world where you know we've
had the division in a world they had a
lot of you know a lot of criticism from
like you know no raids no pvp the
division they remedied that into the
division to I feel like if they had lit
in game they would be showing something
like when hey let me finish
and go and tell you how much he's gonna
fraud it Eric
next all of saying I'm not saying it is
the end-all be-all everybody is
overweight no I'm not saying I'm just
saying that what was represented in the
trailer was the game so the wow factor
off rip is there that that's that's just
facts the second thing is the speed of
the game I thought it was gonna be this
slow lumbering you know I'm saying tight
and fully he kind of no no this is Iron
Man the game at least the range of class
that I played
that's Iron Man the game the verticality
the flying hovering the moves the sword
melee come down crash to earth lit so
off off the wow factor off the graphics
they go and get people that's this one
too there's a lot of people that don't
like PvP and want some real deep story
and they definitely seem like they got
it in place with the Bioware you're
insane so I'm gonna give them that
there's still questions I have like
again like what attic is about to loot
to endgame right
we don't know all we know about is the
stronghold shout or mad cactus HD he
went out there you know I'm saying they
got the strongholds right and to me that
feel like the incursians d remembered
incursions from that's I mean division
really know ray kind of like you know
whatever ornery for right what is prod
re and I got to call him out and my man
CAC has put this out please watch one of
his latest videos is that like destiny
and division when you get a loot drop
you walk over it okay cool and me going
to me let me see should I put this on
for my understanding they don't have
that like whatever you go into the game
with is what you're wearing and then
when you drop something you don't get to
see it just say like legendary or
whatever whatever and then when you go
back to village this then you can look
at this is equivalent to play it destiny
or this stuff drop on the planet but you
gotta go to space this yeah you gotta go
back to the tower to go see what it like
I don't like that aspect schools for yes
there is a new new effect to it yes they
are doing something different that is a
big deal keys
in game content
they sustain it Luke mechanic you know
and if there has legs that's the only
thing I'm saying but if they do it's
over then I'll say it so what I'm gonna
- oh my god when I get the eight player
rates didn't they actually get a system
together it's right out again these sea
legs some aren't you guys a king king
you know what I'm waiting on anthem what
it goes in that vault have a day when i
pre-ordered it i pre-ordered the
expensive one hoping for some XP me
likey a plane like I said we got that
going on if y'all don't like it like
King said yeah get the ei axis you get
any comb refrain cold give out somebody
got out me to chat and they said but
what about the PlayStation people mm-hmm
you don't access or if you're on PC then
you do the origin thing watch what you
do is you get out of later
so for Xbox oh my god if you go get EA
access because this other stuff
happening in the world it's not isolated
what what are your feelings are both
games that's fun that you see with the
latest updates
what me yeah you I still watch that but
uh you know when it comes to answer the
biggest thing that I need to see is I'm
very very cautious that they haven't
came out at least saying they have a
rate type activity in their game and you
know obviously I know that you know they
gotta be done with they don't like I'm
expecting one but it's like it's like
I'm saying it's like I'm with King it's
like you're being really quiet about
your in-game for some reason like
extremely quiet in this game is really
all before lunch damn well they gotta
say something like I do feel like you
you know what the you know the division
didn't have a raid and they got dish
droid for I feel like they'd be stupid
not to at least admit they have one like
you know at least in common they did on
Game Informer stream now the lead dev
did admit that there is an end game
content it's just that it's gonna come
which they're not ready in game like
this week or next week or something like
that
when gig come out but that's not to say
you know we we still don't know we still
got about a month that they can gave me
a IGN first they're doing on it on
anthem right now so we could get it you
know maybe IGN is the one that's
supposed to reveal that I hope that they
you know like I like raise it I feel
like if they really build off raids it
because especially how their their
gameplay it's like they could make
phenomenal raids right it's just like I
don't I'm just get a have to see it like
I got with the whole division not having
a raid you know they clearly saw a raid
support they're like we got eight name
right like they see that support PvP you
know they didn't come out there and they
try to say you know we got the dark zone
that's for you now I guess what in the
division 2 we got four view fours like
they saw what was up and I feel like
when it comes to this genre
there's not enough room for three one of
these is going to get pushed out
regardless how good it is and you know
it could be destiny because that is that
is you know the old one if they only
have expansions and they come in out of
two brand-new games right or it could be
the anthem because anthems coming out if
it's first iteration and it doesn't have
you know that timeframe - oh they don't
like this okay they don't like this okay
like you know it just it could be
either/or I don't think it's going with
the division I think the divisions going
to be there to stay anybody who has a PC
the PC version is not the console
version
the PC version is its own beliefs it has
his own sliders it has its own viewer
sense it has its own actually the PC
version from the ground up is made
exclusively for the PC now that the the
console not gonna add a pro yeah I mean
I would you saying what do you feel so
you you're more along side the divisions
gonna be the one that survives right at
it that's what you say I just got to see
when it comes to we'll see what these IG
and far see if they you know do a little
bit more when it comes to showing that
in-game content because that's all I
care about like yeah you know a lot of
people make fun of destiny players that
say the sentence the game doesn't start
to you beat to get you yeah you know
people like to make fun of us for saying
that but these kind of games they you
can't compare these to your average game
like these kind of games it really does
start when the game ends and I need to
see what you have to do after that
because right now the divisions showing
me more because they know that they got
ridiculed for not showing more and for
not having it yeah let me jump in
shouted your hands li-ion apart he said
not everybody likes space shooters
division has more legs I'm gonna comment
on division here's the thing it's been
impressing me every single time us here
and again that's another one I did get a
chance to play 83 so it's like the thing
that's impressed me dough is the new PvP
and dogs on got me really excited like
to have three dogs on areas like that I
call them already large like we got the
two suckers olds I call the suckers oh
yeah where exactly what would be that's
where everybody is that an even gear
level weapon level no one's gonna have
these tremendous advantages you know I'm
saying and and those are the ones where
it's more about actually skill and then
you be whoever you beat then you get the
gear out of there you know I'm saying
you call up the helicopter whatever you
get out of it
then they got the one or they call it
the occupier zone that's what I'm
calling the gangsters on that's the one
for the hardcore Division one players
who have been grinding crazy who got the
crazy high-level the gear sets of noir
lat and if they won't go in there they
want to shack somebody they can shake
someone it doesn't say like like
that's gonna be for the true hardcore
and the fact that they rotate those
three souls that's kind of fiery awesome
that's hot you don't say these games if
I could get a committed freaking team
dog what'd you get the visit I don't
want to hear that I don't want to hear
that kid I know I try to get you on
destiny all the time with equal players
out there listen so we got the dogs on
going to revamp like King said they had
that first game to learn from every
mistake they made they listened to the
community and said okay boom yeah I
don't like the encouragement we got a
raid now eight play a raid that's crazy
to me who's throwing that Danny Burton
you got to see the mechanics where I
grew a go we got it in matchmaking I
don't know they have a said of his mouth
hope they haven't said they said the
arms child to slow mo yeah at the time
the kill was lowered so all that beef
that I had what I shoot to do with the
hoodie 80 times should be resolved now
you know I'm saying so they got that and
the big ace in the hole to solve TLC is
free DLC is key
yeah so right what what I'm seeing kid
is that anthem comes out mm-hmm guess
that wow factor the people who've never
seen anything like that
oh man it's crazy they're gonna get that
bass but for some reason I just feel
division got the long game to keep you
playing coming back to keep things to do
you know I'm saying kind of thing so
we're gonna see and it looks like they
got as far as trust go I do trust you
saw with the visions I feel like the
Division two
yeah I forgot questions about anthem
still being surrounded be Phantom is
free as well and the child
we got a confirm again not know about
that yes right it's correct that's
correct
he's correctly anthem has said DLC is
free no I don't I'm not sure kid did you
hear anything yeah yeah that's was one
of the like the big announced with a
combination last year because they're
not going to have a season pass
well if that's about what no purchasable
is you know how hot you look how hot
things up you'll be so blessed they
gotta keep it true
they've already could there's already
confirmed this loot boxes in the gator
some want to comment on it man so that's
where we got on a planet cuz when they
got a divvy it up beside that call it's
gonna be a good bet I think so like
based on this week's information I'm
leaning towards division 2 but if like
if I flip flop every week man both of
them look good we gotta see what's going
on anybody else whatever it is you know
we definitely play squad up no
definitely got something real quick for
we move on yeah yeah people that want to
play anthem because you know it looks as
a nice game cool for you but the people
that want to play add seem to kill
destiny yeah not about that life
angry goddess even if they pull it off
you know each hours tella we need the
word xenon better anyways Lord addict
Activision see what's going on
Activision wants to you know complain
about you know giving complaint about
underselling of games like sorry so
people keep trying to call me on
Facebook they keep trying to you know
they're complaining about the
underwhelming gate they keep cutting
divisions and and but Blizzard it looks
like the you know they're cutting jobs
they're they they're complaining about
destiny and underperforming and you know
we don't know if they willingly cut that
or not so we have to you know when more
information comes out about that but you
know what they are down for giving new
see CFOs or CFOs one of the other
they're given them a fifteen million
dollar bonus just for signing that nine
I feel like I feel like a company that's
always saying games are underperforming
its underperforming so much but you know
someone that just takes the job can you
know take what a marketing budget for a
game could be yes right was what's out
of it vet he said I wonder how do people
that Blizzard who are worrying about
layoffs and getting told to slash their
budgets feel about this so when you got
the fifteen Millie signing bonus on top
of it
damn that's that's something I look kid
what you feel about this but I missed
the first part in the account yes I'll
go there I wanted to get paid fifteen
million
yeah just to take the job yes to take
profession I sounds like a cry for help
exactly you you're gonna have to pay me
to take over this you know this train
wreck that I'm taking over like listen
man when you when you're in a position
like that that's that's what happens I
did this take place before or after the
bungee split Oh business this is I
believe after January 13th looks like
his when shreya put it out so we're
gonna say that before it was I'm gonna
say the Activision split was around last
week the seventeen so it does feel
before it does for slightly before like
the timing seems almost the same week
ish kinda and I'm gonna say
they they brought you exactly what it's
like I mean dude wait one of you guys
have like the details of like how to
happen cuz I might win it might win it
feels like you know first for education
all right let's split this whole will
stop a partnership with Bungie not me
you start making executive decisions
that like for instant return I don't
know man but that is crazy out like I
know who else has done something like
that do you know any other publisher
news to me it speaks it speaks to the
grave nature of the situation yeah I
remember this happened because their
former CFO basically they're firing him
their pride
they're they're firing him after the
fact because he basically took the
position that Netflix while he was still
he had it necessarily indicated he was
looking to move forward which is why
they fired him now if you think about it
someone in that position to leave a
position they're in already in that way
and not handled it that professionally
that means he's running from this
situation
take a job you you you don't make it
clear to your current employers that
you're not happy in your looking to move
forward you you make an agreement with
someone while you're still ahead of
another company while not informing your
employers that you've taken another
position yeah I mean there has to be
some situation anyway we don't know the
ins and outs of what happened on this
space get to that space so you can look
at me as morally bankrupt as well but
I'm gonna do exactly like old you did
in the do games the dude is coming in I
have no issues from him you take that 15
mil whatever they give you you take
that's their problem you know and then
you deal with whatever issues and you
you're walking into but there dude and
walked out I'm again listen you're human
being I was not happy the reason that
they were gay that they gave him that
there has to be some kind of clause that
he has to stay there for a certain
amount of time good point they don't
want someone just come in there and
leaving yes so we're in the bushes and
we'll pay you to get a couple of months
he's like I'm really feeling this you
you wanna feel this until the 15 million
wash off for you it could have been bad
that's his bonus up front instead of
live I said in being paid like glittered
online or after quarters he just kind of
got like a guaranteed bonus regardless
of like milestone so I probably like you
know that I'll take a job but you have
to give me whatever bonus like it's
funny though because they have been
crying about layoffs and all this other
stuff like there's no better argument
for unionization then acting there's all
of 2018 telling employees to cut costs
then get 15 million to the new CFO I
don't know we'll see I don't know the
ins and out I'm not gonna pretend to
know the ins and outs of it but yeah
it's just it to me just go to show where
Activision is that right now you know
I'm saying at the end of it is like you
know all the franchises that they have
either have lost be easily lost it with
destiny or they've lost some luster from
it you know like coal duties called duty
but at the end of the day like the rest
of the franchise I would say Connor want
to decline some of the more so you know
we gotta see desperate times call for
desperate measures
but that oh I got everybody anything
else order attic on your own topic with
the CFO no they bunches it's slimeballs
but if you got a do something like okay
I just want to go real quick you know in
a quick two sentences what would you do
to fix EA if you see a CEO
ei or Activision is activated Oh
Activision I mean pretty much you could
do the same thing for both but what's
the acting I would never let destiny go
like I would have never I don't give a
damn what y'all want like I really don't
like I really don't care I really don't
care how you feel about the situation
I'm gonna stall arm you all the way to
the floor I don't care I don't know that
kid what would you do with Activision
he's a kid all using Bush's article Mike
was on mute good you said what I would
do what Activision yeah if you two CFO
what's the first what's the first thing
how do you how do you plug these you
know bad times right now it's a lot
going on why do I get the feeling that
Microsoft's gonna get brought up in this
um I mean I would um I mean did here's
the thing they got one thing that's like
guaranteed you know they well a couple
things they got they got Diablo right
yeah they got the overwatch thing right
mm-hmm
and they have deer call duties you got
three Studios for call of duty now if
I'm them I mean if I'm not looking to
like acquire by any new studios or
anything like that I'm gonna look for
more ways to monetize those Call of Duty
games and see if I can get more money
out of PlayStation and Xbox double
mutism as Mike what is marketing dollars
to see not the consumer like I'm gonna
find a way they like because I'm like
man I'm like say the truth you will find
a way to change the public so you know
different than the last so what you just
said is exactly what they just did to
get them exactly where they are so you
won't do more of the same
how you got money to give just to get 15
million for accepting the job that's
nothing but Luke box in my view what
would you do to fix it yeah literally go
to do I'm a double down I mean really
but according to their state is their
projections they're a little yeah
because they had nothing coming out
right so I mean the only thing that's
coming out it's called duty they got
nothing to support that you have to rush
out another Diablo deglass to find ways
they make more announcements for
overwatch some more character
announcements see if Excel box or - I
don't know like I think that nurse move
is corrupted your soul man yeah no it's
movie I don't know it's all I think the
hottest thing they got to me is is
overwatch my own watch is that way so I
didn't that thing loses luster you got a
soggy I'm ready for overwatch to that I
mean it's cool but it's still big though
oh what's the big I mean it's alright
with it's not real listen don't front
don't front like that big a hundred
thousand pounds dude walk through the
room from epic I'll tell you this though
if they come they make an announcement
of overwatch to new can of paint story
full-featured nor let people gonna be
hype that's a huge the next overwatch
better have a story with all these damn
in that care or a freakin identity
crisis they keep playing Laura the game
and all this like if they really do that
they got something there I gotta get to
me Corre Corre do they're gonna be fine
with that but every knee in Diablo
obviously for the pipeline that's a big
one they think they need now they lost
their something they need whatever is
the new wave like if there was another
game yeah like
there wasn't control like out like say
fortnight they need their next big wave
the kind of sign and lock-in because
that's how they move right it kind of
here that was the hottest they want to
lock in so they got a fine with the new
wave even is to try to try to get that
early with you things they need to break
from Blizzard then I never see I have
never seen two companies with more
conflicting ideologies in bed together
it makes no sense it makes no sense a
break it is better for Activision and
it's definitely better for Blizzard and
that way they can they can just refocus
on themselves both companies can we
focus on what makes them good because
since Blizzard is gone with them just
the way they've rolled out
you know their their IP isn't great and
Activision is pretty much stopped making
games besides Call of Duty I've done
anything else anything else that's up of
no with Activision is Blizzard stuff
apart from Call of Duty walking away
from that damn Warcraft money I'm just
saying what's best for them what they
gonna do that's the thing though if the
if the if the partnership continues as
it is
they're killing Blizzard they are
killing Blizzard ten generations behind
so you see current consoles are in
position to handle the Warcraft how many
times that we got to go to e3 and we are
hoping for that game console and for a
long time now that game had that game
should have been on consoles a long time
ago so I got attic Kings before you get
out anything on this Activision thing no
attic you good yeah I'm pretty good what
the only thing I would probably do is
you know try to I think they're done
with the single-player stuff I do I
think for the most part they're done
with that
maybe because they they don't even
really have the studios the pop stuff
out like that you know put more funding
and Blizzard because I think right now
that's their only role you know way to
Berta bring up the revenue is what
Blizzard you know a Diablo I think it's
gonna sell well but at the end of the
day I don't know if they're gonna try to
go extra of microtransactions in Diablo
and that might get them bad feed but
addict are you thinking are you saying
you think they'd not gonna have single
playing call of duty this year or or
just a solo single play looming I'm not
doing anymore
I think they've confirmed that they're
doing a single-player next year but King
they're they're going to do the very
minimum possible and they're gonna get
like lets they didn't do a Call of Duty
they did the blackout mode which
probably you know they don't have to do
too much to make that cuz if you've ever
played blackout it runs well but it
looks horrible it's you know they're
going to they're they're trying to not
spend dimes and spend pennies and bring
in dollars yeah shell this little
miniature he's like wow definitely and
he said now with mouse and keyboard
support especially like on Xbox I should
make it better bring over you know I'm
saying so yeah I mean it's a lot of
possibilities man they got things they
can do so I'm not on some war with
Activision yeah anyway that's what we
got let's get to this poll new ILP poll
for the week with the recent mortal
kombat eleven reveal how do you feel
about the lack of information or
gameplay footage regarded it a
disappointing
switch owners deserve to be treated as
the Xbox one and PlayStation 4 be why
ruin a good event with a slash show of
downgraded graphics [ __ ] I don't care
unless we get that smash a little
compact crossover we deserve
that is the question next one man you
gotta have the other one oh we should
just throw it all in the bushes Rio
people when he goes up on Twitter
tomorrow
Loic kids move with the Cameo what is
going on sir and people find you man you
can find me on twitter at kids smooth or
if you like playstation stuff at kid
nerd don't bat on twitter check out my
youtube i've been back to regular video
making so uh thanks but thanks for
having me guys no doubt what about that
planet xbox we're still on Wednesdays at
sometime between 8:00 p.m. and 9:00 p.m.
Eastern uh so so Wednesday night you
know is me at it continue know whenever
you what's show up I know we we got some
we got some stuff coming up that's gonna
hinder on his parents I know Kingdom
Hearts is coming soon yeah Rowley movie
I know I know he had to travel to go see
that thought I was some Netflix stuff
right he's like oh I was gonna actually
go somewhere I know that big of a deal
but my bad but I put in the chat I was
like okay I was like how mad would you
be on a scale from one to ten if I
didn't show it to Planet Xbox like to go
watch an anime Dragon Ball movie he just
said really question mark I was like
okay so 20 out of 10 gosh I literally
movie that addict in that seat my bad
plan X man love what you guys are doing
shout to grab my gears my boy maids Merc
you don't saying the crew off again I
forget what screw a week over you ask
the crew right there no doubt adequate
Len Len job like a soccer team snowstorm
what you got going nothing
he has nothing going on with my hand
yeah you can definitely find me not at
the barley movie no you can find me on a
planet Xbox this Wednesday from 8:30 to
9:00 p.m. I know it's a huge window but
you're gonna have to work with us
you can find me there you don't find me
there next week because uh Kingdom Arts
is out I've already informed I will not
be there
nice Kingdom Hearts we got gave out
giveaway saluted oh no doubt and you
definitely appreciate their the patience
with my weather situation or down oh now
you already know shoe slobs out to work
his mover for saving us in the eleventh
hour on a fourth chair that's what's up
no doubt Lord saw where you can find
people friends what you got going on sir
first yeah they did this move coming
through mmm
always a pleasure and uh yeah you can
find me on Twitter Lords of IOP PSN xbox
live at BX sovereign or
next week we'll be talking about res Evo
- I am going to mysteriously get sick
Thursday evening and and I'll be playing
that game two ways meant to be played
midnight in the dark lights out
[Music]
Lord king fantastic combat oh wow yeah
listen guys I'm gonna give you an
official combat tour later I don't know
what the hell was going on with the
internet and all that no I do not have
Comcast boss moves go away rightfully so
like I don't have my PC running all day
so when I do come down I just turned it
off for this and I'm going video editing
or whatever I'm doing um everybody we
are gonna make a great announcement so
we're gonna roll two packs right now so
we're all geared up and ready to go to
get two packs and after and finish with
packs uh then we go to e3 but um
everybody that wants to link up with us
at packs link up with us so we can start
to collaborate I want y'all all to start
you know unifying these things now
Mabhida fact about next box in the
building I think we might get PXA an ILP
collab like that's it this is what I'm
talking about
I really must wicked Smoove I really do
because the kids energy is fantastic his
uh his leadership as far as his podcast
goals and stuff like that it is evident
and he's trying to get out to these
events and stuff like that to give his
content push that forward that is
necessary in our climate today so um
please uh like follow subscribe on his
channel as well make sure you go there
because I'm telling you he's infectious
and it's fun he's really fun right so
yeah definitely if you want to see
PlayStation controllers being broke
shout to the Lord because we were there
with number that moment from pax man and
also one of my standouts was uh cold
vain everybody's playing oh is his
birthday today these plans you know
Dante e Johnson a little Maggie is old
he got to take in all the Latin we went
clothes shopping yesterday see see the
new threads you know
be cave I shot it so put them now one
day to the little king you know eternal
realm that's what's up man yeah Barry
you'll have to fight me for that though
fossil a cease a great show first time
watching the podcast thank you brother
much appreciate ya make sure you guys
hit that like subscribe that
notification gang man I'm gonna speak
the carboxy we get the audio up later
you know I'm saying and also you guys
got to get in our discord Lords a gaming
discord is lit please get in there it's
crazy and I'm sayin
Oh for me I muted yeah people found out
that I'm a fraud what they do is they at
me please check out God King got that
combat talk up there you know what I'm
saying with that Pacquiao all that good
stuff and of course the last word my
Brandon eat Bacchus is up this week we
deep dive but threat division and doing
God's work show oh man you gonna stop
that but anyway that's all I got if
anybody's got anything else no everybody
join these playoff games enjoy your
Sunday we catch you next week let's go
pay you guys one Yeti two guys